good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-705 object class
safe special containment procedures
scp-705 requires little security detail
nor significant clearance to access and
is to be held in Sector two safe SCP
containment with the lid closed and the
access is to be logged when entering and
exiting scp-705 s containment to be
reviewed once a month
miss placement or lack of attendance
leading to containment failure is
punishable by temporary removal of
access repeated offenses incur more
severe probations scp-705 is not to be
used in any practical applications
[Music]
description scp-705 is normally
contained within a 5 ounce container of
children's molding compound commonly
known as play-doh while properly sealed
scp-705 exhibits no unusual qualities or
anomalous behaviour scp-705 was
originally discovered within the
corporation's research labs and as part
of an attempt to create a self molding
product the means by which this was
accomplished is still unknown
but the results led to the abandonment
of the line and the labs themselves
retrieved on scp-705 was originally
moved to syphon then relocated a month
later to its current location at site 17
when the lid for the container holding a
CP 705 is opened the soft red material
inside will begin to animate shapes
resembling small humanoid forms will
emerge from the clay slowly at first but
soon numbering in the tens to hundreds
the material comprising the men will
sculpt and come into detail appearing as
miniature infantrymen in typical
military fatigues equipped with fully
functional automatic weaponry
at this point scp-705 comprises
approximately 2,200 individual sentient
organisms when active scp-705 is
incredibly violent and militaristic
possessing a highly territorial mindset
and will do everything in its power to
overtake what it perceives to be a
strategic location within observed
environments this will be perceived as a
lab workstation a break room coffee
machine or a bathroom sink due to the
weak composition of each scp-705
organism
none of these threats can be considered
significant and can be diffused with any
application of force unconstrained
scp-705 is no more than a minor
annoyance although not for lack of
trying
scp-705 has been observed to be capable
of sentient thought and audio recordings
have revealed that they possess
understanding of the English language
over time the group that comprises
scp-705 will become more complex with
obvious leadership roles emerging on
several occasions an extended test of
scp-705 as shown the formation of larger
more complex structures formed from the
collective mass such as tanks apcs
and even aircraft such as helicopters of
bombers it is to be noted that none of
these creations are any more effective
due to the harmless clay ammunition
if scp-705 comes into contact with a
similar compound such as a normal
container of play-doh the contacted
material will take on the same qualities
as active scp-705 when of the same color
no differences in behavior are noted
although larger and more complex objects
will be observed if the affected
substance is of a different color
however an entirely new army is created
if left undisturbed the original scp-705
organisms and the new opposing army will
engage in combat
multiple colors can be activated in this
manner and alliances will form between
the aggressing parties said materials
will remain active until scp-705 is once
again contained scp-705 is fully capable
of sustaining casualties amongst
themselves in these conflicts although
such losses are mitigated by its
amorphous nature
addendum 705 D the first known attack by
a CP 705 occurred on when the container
had been left unattended on a counter
within the break room in less than an
hour scp-705 had taken control of the
mr. coffee machine declaring
independence and control over the region
the assault was routed when dr. Wright's
brushed them away from the burner
resulting in massive casualties and a
complete rout interviews with scp-705
remarked on this day with great fear and
resentment
addendum 705 F after gaining approval
from o5 6 scp-705 was introduced to
scp-963 at which point 705 sought out
the current holder of 963 when contact
was made the soldiers making up as CP
705 saluted dr. Brent and stood at ease
awaiting orders so let's save this for
when we really need it ok that was a
short lecture today but this is where it
ends thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Pichette Muslim Mookie Jax
Merrick Pierce M Hamlin Austin Thomas
Aldridge
Desmond Hoskins Depp's McGee
dr. mortis Johnno Porter Cody tench
Tiber ball on sighs seven actual if you
would like a special thank you at the
end of each of my videos and some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]